cuántas caras tiene la siguiente figura
pausa en este vídeo y traten de
resolverlo muy bien supongo que ya
pasaron el vídeo vamos a resolverlos
juntos en realidad lo que voy a hacer es
tratar de colorear las caras así que
tenemos esta cara en la parte de atrás
esta es una cara luego tenemos esta cara
también en la parte de atrás y esta es
una figura transparente por eso es que
podemos ver las caras de la parte de
atrás entonces esta es la segunda cara
ahora tenemos esta cara triangular en la
parte de arriba déjenme colorear la esta
es una cara triangular en la parte de
arriba
y es nuestra tercera cara y también
tenemos esta cara triangular en la parte
de abajo esta va a ser nuestra cuarta
cara
y la pregunta clave es ya terminamos
parece que ya colocamos todas las caras
que podemos ver pero hay algo aquí un
poco complicado hay una cara a través de
la cual estamos viendo las de atrás
déjenme escoger otro color
es la cara frontal a través de la que
estamos viendo las otras a través de
esta estamos viendo las caras 1 2 y 4
así que esta va a ser nuestra cara
número 5 la forma en que dibujaron esto
es como si fuera de vidrio así que
podemos ver las caras 1 2 y 4 pero esta
es nuestra quinta cara así que esta
figura tiene 5 caras muy bien hagamos
otro ejemplo pero en lugar de caras
vamos a pensar en bordes así que cuántos
bordes tiene la siguiente figura pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo muy
bien trabajemos juntos en esto voy a
contar los bordes un borde es donde se
juntan dos caras aquí tenemos un borde
este es un borde aquí atrás tenemos otro
borde y lo podemos ver porque esta
figura es transparente este es nuestro
segundo borde
este de acá es nuestro tercer borde
este otro es nuestro cuarto borde
luego tenemos otro borde de este lado
que es nuestro quinto borde
también tenemos este que es nuestro
sexto borde
nos queda este otro que es nuestro
séptimo borde
y por último pero no menos importante
tenemos este otro borde que es nuestro
octavo borde y fue muy bueno que
marcáramos los bordes con rojo porque
así nos aseguramos de que no nos falte
ninguno o que no contemos ninguno dos
veces entonces esta figura tiene ocho
bordes
si tienen curiosidad y solo por hacer un
ejercicio extra cuántas caras tiene esta
figura bueno vamos a contarlas aquí
atrás tenemos una por aquí atrás también
tenemos otra la segunda cara esta es
nuestra tercera cara que es la base y es
una cara cuadrada y tenemos dos caras al
frente esta cara que es transparente y
por la que vemos las de atrás
y luego tenemos esta otra cara por la
que también vemos las de atrás y aunque
solo nos preguntan los bordes por hacer
una práctica extra encontramos las caras
de esta figura un cuadrado que es la
base y luego cuatro caras triangulares
para formar una pirámide cuadrangular
esta figura tiene ocho bordes y cinco
caras